foreign
[Music]
I have a slightly complicated
relationship with breakfast
I can hate American breakfast breakfast
breakfast breakfast
to the first meal of the day breakfast
breakfast breakfast
a couple years ago I made several videos
condemning American breakfast for being
too sweet and then proceeded to tell you
about how cultured I was because I
discovered other breakfast traditions
and integrated them into my life in
order to stop hating breakfast and it
worked but one thing I failed to mention
during all of this breakfast commentary
is that
I ate Doritos for breakfast
like all the time
[Music]
yes I eat them with chopsticks for
obvious reasons
see my fingers
squeaky clean
[Music]
wait I gotta tell you something really
quick um I made a video about China and
the United States and their economic War
over microchips it's really insane that
video is live right now you can go watch
it on nebula in fact you can watch every
one of my videos a week early and it
costs you just over one US dollar a
month using a hack that I will explain
at the end of the video for now let's
just keep swimming in a sea of Doritos
[Music]
but no I'm serious this is a real thing
one of Nick's jobs our studio manager is
to make sure that there are Doritos
always stocked in the studio and to be
honest he does an excellent job you like
your job Nick I love my job I love your
job dude
Nick has another part of his job that's
slightly related I'm now realizing I'll
tell you about that later I was recently
at a wedding in Canada getting slightly
Rowdy and during the party I had a
conversation with my friend Becky I was
telling her about how much I love
Doritos and especially for breakfast the
first thing Becky did is tell me how
much better Canadian chips are
especially Canadian Doritos she promised
that she would send me Canadian Doritos
and indeed she did oh yes we have
Doritos from Canada and we have
Chopsticks thank you Becky but then she
also asked me why the breakfast snob
over here who's like condemning all
things American breakfast eats Doritos
for the first meal of the day but it
turns out there's an answer to this one
that required a little bit of research
some expert interviews and a
conversation with the internet's best
food science explainer and this is just
me spitballing and I'm not a scientist I
just play one on the internet the answer
to this is yet another stop on my long
strange journey of trying to understand
breakfast and its connection to human
evolution and ancient traditions and
perhaps most importantly today's economy
where we live in a world where literal
scientists sit around and engineer food
so that we can't get enough of it try
Doritos they taste as good as they
crunch he's in a better place now it's
corn tomato onions and spices
[Music]
um
oh my God look at this
oh yes dear Johnny hope you like cheese
P.S congrats again on the Emmy
thanks Becky
today we've got zesty cheese
[ __ ]
oh my God it's like nacho cheese with a
kick oh yeah this is good
they're extra salty too the Cornerstone
of any nutritious breakfast this is
amazing Canada kills it with chips okay
let's get this started
I think first we need to talk about
Doritos
Cool Ranch flavor Doritos brand tortilla
chips one heck of a crunch
this is a Dorito
it is a triangle of mashed up corn that
is baked fried and coated with a magical
cheesy powder
this orange dust is a mix of garlic
Romano cheese and cheddar cheese we got
a total of 25 different ingredients on
here and in the case of Cool Ranch no
other chip tastes like cool ranch it's
basically the same ingredients like cool
ranch has a couple of things that I
can't really pronounce here like sodium
acetate disodium
inocinate inocinate disodium
guanylate and crucially both of these
bags plus Becky's Canadian flavor
contain a magic powder called monosodium
glutamate a mysterious thing that I
think is at the center of why I love
this so much and why I want it for
breakfast
Hmm
this is really delicious
this magic ingredient was invented in
Japan 100 or so years ago when this
Japanese chemist was supposedly trying
to figure out why his wife's soup tasted
so damn good he did a bunch of Science
and realized that it was this strip of
kelp which is basically like seaweed but
technically it's not seaweed it's kelp
this was the key ingredient he saw his
wife put this strip of kelp in boiling
water at the beginning of soup making
and then taking it out and whatever
happened during that short time made all
the difference wait a minute this same
thing happens every Monday in my studio
oh it smells good in here Nick what you
making miso soup from you so Monday so
Monday every Monday we have miso soup in
this office because like Doritos miso is
a very important part of my morning yeah
it makes the whole week good it really
does start now with the Japanese cow
from Hokkaido I bought it at my local
Japanese Market Hana Japanese Market
love you guys and what do you do with it
you put it in there like well it's hot
rolling boil for like 20 minutes
take it out as that essential sea flavor
we got the spigot on the other side so
when the soup's done we're gonna
dispense it oh it's very hot we will be
back for the Miso thanks Nick see you
guys
wait but what does this have to do with
Doritos
everything this has everything to do
with Doritos let me explain
I really want some miso soup
oh my God miso soup everything is
because this Japanese chemist discovered
that this seaweed or kelp contained a
bunch of one special molecule called
glutamate or glutamic acid It's actually
an amino acid and it's actually the most
abundant amino acid that you find in
breast milk like the first thing you
taste when you come into this world when
glutamate is present in your mouth it
makes everything you're eating taste
more delicious and more substantial
meaty and more Savory the guy kept
poking around and discovered that this
delicious chemical reaction was not just
happening in his wife's soup from the
Kelp she was putting in but also in a
bunch of other delicious foods like ripe
Tomatoes meat and cheese broths
mushrooms asparagus fish sauce parmesan
cheese the Japanese chemist claimed that
glutamate had such a significant impact
on taste that it deserved its own
classification at the time there were
four major classes of taste sweet sour
salty and bitter he said there should be
a fifth oh and by the way if you've ever
seen this taste map in school like I did
of like where your taste buds taste
things it's kind of BS for Taste
receptors overlap and they're sort of
all over on your tongue anyway that was
a kind of annoying side note let's keep
going he called this taste Umami which
beautifully enough in Japanese roughly
translates to deliciousness
why call it some technical thing when
you just be like it's deliciousness that
is what it will be classified
Umami The Taste experience was
officially recognized by scientists in
the 90s and there's been a lot of really
amazing work on it but the story is only
just beginning because this Japanese
chemist found a way to extract this
delicious flavor from the Kelp and to
mass produce it in the form of a flaky
white salt he called it monosodium
glutamate or MSG pure glutamate put into
the form of assault and this is the key
ingredient that coats all of our Doritos
and makes them delicious
and this is where it all comes together
linking my Dorito craving to my love for
miso soup one a wholesome soup with
countless benefits to my health and the
other a strip of fried corn paste with
really no nutritional value and yet I
crave both of them when I show up to
work in the morning because what I'm
really craving here is the chemical
reaction that produces Umami the Savory
deliciousness either from the glutamic
acid in NYX kelp or from the special
white powder that I often sniff up I
mean that that coats my the surface of
the Doritos
foreign
[Music]
here we go
okay
Don't Mind If I Do hey Nick by the way
is MSG bad for you I don't know why
don't you go ask Adam regusia yeah Adam
reducia I don't know
hey Adam oh there we go hi what's up oh
maybe I'm not miked or hold on sorry I
can't hear you I can probably be oh
check it check any check I've watched
your face for many hours and uh it's
always surreal to be like and now the
guy who I just watched talked to me is
talking to me that's what you think
actually I'm gonna talk right past you
yeah
anyways so MSG I got some right here oh
you have MSG with you right there I I do
too look there you go oh yeah do you
have any aversion to MSG no no no no I
mean it's like it's it's
just it's just one of the chemicals that
you need it's not essential because your
body can make it out of other things but
you still like it for a reason you gotta
have it but too much of anything is not
good for you baby said Barry White too
much of anything
come to think of it he said that for the
purposes of refuting it in the song
because he was saying that in fact he
can't get enough of your love babe There
is no too much there is no too much in
that particular highly rarified case of
your love babe but in all other cases
too much of anything is not good for you
baby and that includes glutamate talking
to Adam ragusio for an hour the guy's
deathly smart on this and he has an
entire video about this MSG the whole
story the chemistry all of it it's like
way deeper than I will ever go on
anything food related go watch that if
you want the Deep Dev on MSG but the
tldr is that MSG got branded as
dangerous because of one short letter to
the editor that spread a rumor a rumor
that Chinese restaurants were very
dangerous because they were putting MSG
in their food even though there wasn't
evidence for that it created this rumor
that has sort of stuck with all of us
today MSG causes migraines for literally
millions of people this is really really
scary and we do not understand the
impact of MSG MSG can cause swelling as
well as chest pains a burning sensation
and an overall feeling of weakness or
maybe more to this public poisoned child
will have permanent impairment of the
brain According to some of these studies
and will grow up like 10 years old
stupid not to mention fat the whole
thing became kind of racist and panicky
and it was also based on the fact that
like we called it we called it MSG
monosodium glutamate instead of calling
it ajinomoto when you get refer to
anything by its chemical name it sounds
scary Aji no whatever but I'm talking to
Adam for one question which is why do I
crave this stuff in the morning we crave
all kinds of things that our body needs
we are evolved to seek out the things
that we need to survive just the
simplest form of evolution you could
ever imagine you know the taste of umami
in food signals to us that we are eating
something that is protein rich and we
need protein in order to replenish our
muscles and do all kinds of other
important things in our body we were
programmed to love it and Gobble it down
because we need it and this is what I've
learned about my craving for Doritos in
the morning it's a big trick what I want
in the morning is the salty Savory
experience of umami I don't want the
Sweet Fluff that comes from traditional
American breakfast with sweet liquid
sugar poured on it again this is what
has led me to [ __ ] about American
breakfast for several years but a very
uncomfortable reality is that in a busy
life making all of this food is kind of
hard takes time takes effort shout out
to Nick
[Music]
how much is enough how big does this
pile have to be
I happen to live at a time in history
where food scientists sit around and use
their brilliant science knowledge to
engineer food that somehow tricks my
brain into thinking it's getting the
food that Evolution has trained my brain
to Crave in other words these chips are
actually tricking my brain into thinking
that I'm eating some protein-rich
wholesome meal but clearly I'm not
there's a there's a historian of science
named Dr Sarah Tracy in Canada her
Central thesis is that all the
conversations we have about whether or
not MSG is bad for you that all kind of
misses the point all of that is small
potatoes like the big potato
is that MSG is really really good at
making garbage Foods taste delicious
making you want to eat the most refined
corn paste that really should be used as
like a packing material rather than a
food but it's unbelievably cheap to make
and lasts forever in a bag and you can
make a person actually want to eat it if
you put MSG on it I mean this was one of
the original aims of the Japanese
chemist who invented MSG he looked
around and saw all these poor farmers
who only had plain rice and vegetables
to eat and he marketed his MSG as a way
to allow these Farmers to elevate their
meals for them to taste more Savory and
more delicious more fulfilling more
satisfying if they just sprinkle this
magic powder on top Cool Ranch
so yeah that is why I eat Doritos for
breakfast because some brilliant
Corporation invented a substance that
tricks my brain into thinking that I'm
eating miso soup or stew or parmesan
cheese or whatever and in the process
they perfected it everything about this
thing is engineered the powder is so
finely ground that it fills every nook
and cranny of your mouth and literally
triggers the release of more saliva
literally making your mouth water
they're crunchy yet light they seem to
melt in your mouth after giving you that
satisfying crunch which tricks your body
into wanting more to be honest I feel
like this is just yet another way that
Corporate America dupes Me by hijacking
my physiology
but that doesn't mean I'm going to stop
eating Doritos for breakfast
thanks for watching everyone see you in
the next one
[Applause]
[Music]
whoa uh yeah it's me again hi everyone
I'm sitting in a sea of Doritos
something I never thought I would do for
my professional career but here I am so
as I mentioned earlier at the beginning
of the video I have made a video that is
an insanely Deep dive into the
geopolitics of China and the United
States who are currently at War over
semiconductors or microchips a piece of
technology that is basically the future
and the tldr is that if you have good
microchips you can do really cool
military stuff anyway I don't want to
give it all away that video goes live
here on the channel next week but I have
started publishing every one of my
videos a week early on nebula nebula is
a creator-owned streaming platform no
ads it is a place where you subscribe
for very very cheap and you get to watch
tons of amazing creators that focus a
lot on like learning about the world I
am now on nebula my whole library is on
nebula ad free and every one of my
videos is going up a week early on
nebula I mean nebula is the streaming
service that literally I watch like it's
the one that I'm into creators like
legal eagle or polymatter or real life
floor have exclusive content that you
can't get anywhere else like this one
from your life floor called modern
conflict which is just awesome super
high quality stuff that you can get if
you are subscriber to nebula so the big
question is how much does it cost
everyone wants to know how much it costs
the answer is if you go through the
front door it's like five bucks a month
or 15 bucks a year pretty good deal but
you can get it for just over a dollar a
month if you use the hack that I'm about
to explain go to the link in my
description and it will take you to
curiositystream which is a partner of
nebula curiosity stream itself is a huge
repository of amazing high quality
documentaries with like big names like
David Attenborough and tons of really
interesting stuff but the point here is
if you sign up for literally the
cheapest plan on curiosity stream using
this special link and use my code you
gotta use my code in order to get the
discount and to support my channel you
will get an email from nebula saying hey
you now have a nebula account make a
password and now you have access to
every one of my videos a week early plus
tons of other exclusive content from
other creators all ad free it's an
insanely good deal and what I love most
about it is it's all Creator owned these
are a bunch of creators who got together
and made a streaming service it allows
us to make really cool ambitious stuff
not have to worry about like ad friendly
guidelines like we have to Here on
YouTube anyway this is an insane deal
and uh it's a way to support this
channel too when you click that link and
use that code I'm trying to establish a
presence on nebula not only with
publishing a video a week early but if
enough people sign up using my code and
they see that there's a lot of interest
for my audience they will fund a
documentary project that I've been
wanting to work on for a really long
time a really deep ambitious original
that will live only on nebula so the
link is in the description the code is
Johnny Harris with no spaces and I am
sitting in a sea of Doritos for some
reason thank you all for being here I
hope you enjoyed this Doritos piece and
uh I'll see you soon okay bye foreign